pourrait se demander pourquoi on
ne construirait pas TGV qui
serait beaucoup plus rapide.
PABLO RODRIGUEZ, leader du gouv.
à la Chambre des communes
- Québec, Trois-Rivières,
Montréal, l'Ontario vont
être plus proche que jamais.
- Économie de temps : voici
le principal avantage du projet
de train à grande fréquence
entre Toronto et Québec,
selon le gouvernement fédéral.
Le tracé préliminaire,
qui prévoit plusieurs arrêts,
permettrait de réduire
de 30 minutes le trajet entre
Québec et Montréal, et de
90 minutes celui entre Ottawa
et Toronto.
Avec un coût pouvant aller
jusqu'à 12 milliards de dollars,
cet expert croit qu'on devrait
plutôt investir dans un TGV,
beaucoup plus rapide.
MICHEL ARCHAMBAULT, professeur
émérite en tourisme, ESG UQAM
- Vous avez à choisir,
soit vous dépensez 12 milliards
dans un train oui, certes,
qui va apporter une certaine
evolution ou vous investissez
20 à 22 milliards dans un train
qui va apparaître comme
une révolution et qui va changer
le comportement.
HUGO LAPORTE, citoyen
- Je pense que c'est bien
qu'on ait plus de fréquences
pour les trains, plus de choix
que seulement très tôt le matin,
une fois l'après-midi, une fois
le soir.
JOSÉE LANGUÉRAND, citoyenne
- Le train Québec-Toronto,
je ne sais pas si c'est
une bonne idée, je ne sais pas
s'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
le prennent. C'est peut-être
une dépense inutile.
- Avec une propulsion
électrique, le TGV a aussi
l'avantage d'être plus
écologique et de pouvoir
concurrencer l'avion.
- Il est deux fois plus rapide,
d'autre part, il fait appel
à une technologie éprouvée,
électrique à 100 %,
contrairement au TGF
qu'on nous a présenté,
étant en grande partie
électrifié, mais également
au diesel, donc émetteur
de GES encore une fois.
- Le projet de TGF tient
toutefois la route pour
la mairesse de Montréal.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Il faut qu'on puisse, comme
société, se donner des moyens
de transport rapides, efficaces,
entre les métropoles.
C'est comme ça qu'on va pouvoir
soutenir tout l'écosystème
économique.
- Et revenir sur la planche
à dessin n'est de pas la chose
à faire, croit le porte-parole
en matière de Transports du Bloc
Québécois.
XAVIER BARSALOU-DUVAL, porte-
parole du BQ en transports
- Ça veut dire que si on décide
d'arrêter le TGF puis d'y aller
avec un TGV, bien, on repart
à zéro.
- Des consultations sur
le trajet du projet sont prévues
cet automne, auprès notamment
de 36 communautés autochtones.
Ici Danielle Kadjo, Radio-
Canada, Montréal